today's tutorial is on Python slice my
name is Richard Kirchner with the simply
learned team that's WW simpler calm get
certified get ahead will give a brief
definition of slice and then with
something like slicing you really need
to look at the code and see what it's
doing
what is lacing and python slicing is the
extraction of part of a string list or
tuple so you can look at that if we have
the word cat and we want to slice out
the a in the middle that would be a
slice if we have a list names Frank
Betty bid George we want to slice out
maybe every name that begins with the
letter A so we'd end up with a bit you
say have a list of objects and a tuple
is similar to a list except that you
can't alter those once you have a tuple
that's a locked variable which can then
be used to as a key code for other
things the syntax is you have your
object whether it's a string a list or a
tuple and you have start/stop and step
all divided by colons this is important
to note that these are integers so you
can't put a float value in there you'll
get an error and they can't be negative
so if your start is a minus one then it
goes to the end of whatever you're
looking at and goes backwards and
Counting and same thing with stop and
with step we're going from the end going
backward and we'll look at all these to
show you exactly how they work it's
important to note that whatever you're
doing these have to be integers positive
or negative and so we have an object
equals a slice and then we have our
different increments in there and the
object itself that is returned is a
variable so we set that variable so
we're gonna go ahead and jump in and
look at the code whatever a Python
editor you're using will work fine for
this because this is just a standard
Python functions there's no special
modules we're importing by myself like
Jupiter notebook and I use it out of the
Anaconda that's just nice because it
creates what they call a virtual
environment meaning that whatever I add
into that environment or take out isn't
going to affect the rest of my computer
until I'm ready to install it on the
main computer it keeps everything
separate and it can test out my
different modules PyCharm is another
wonderful one again that has an in
virtual environment for regular python
editing
so use Notepad plus plus and there's a
number of other editors out there so any
editor will work so here I am in my
anaconda navigator and you can see that
the Anaconda actually creates a virtual
environment for all kinds of different
things not just Python which is nice
because sometimes I jump back and forth
with our studio or some other package
and we'll go ahead and launch our
Jupiter and Jupiter will open up in
whatever browser you have set for your
main browser and since I have Python I
believe it's three six on this
particular one I can go over here to the
right where it says new and we'll do a
new Python 3 so this is done in Python 3
point 6 3 7 is out at this time although
it doesn't work with a couple of other
modules I use I stick with the 3 6 and
the three things that we're gonna look
at if you remember correctly there's a
list I made one here we're not going to
show the tuples this an identical list
as far as its functionality but usually
when you see a tuple there we go
it's 10 of squared brackets we put the
curved brackets on there to denote it's
a tuple I could have also done it like
this instead of creating a tuple this
way I could have just as easily call
this tuple 0 equals a tuple of lists so
this is now a tuple and if I print these
out I can print out our list I can print
out either tuple or tuple 0 it doesn't
matter and you'll see how it does need
something the same way we designated it
use the square brackets let you know
that this is an array or list by the
ways array is one of those terms you'll
hear a lot they call it a list in Python
but sometimes people call this an array
this array of values the difference is
is that I can go into an array and I can
change the four to a three or something
like that or maybe make the 4 or 14 in
the array without changing any other
part of the array with the tuple I have
to rewrite the whole tuple it's locked
in there I can't just look at position
the one at the beginning and change that
to a zero I would have to create a whole
new tuple and this is done because if
you're using it as a key code for
something or as an ID you don't want to
be able to manipulate it you want to be
locked in and that's why you have a
tuple versus a list and then of course
we have our string like it strings in
just a minute - we will be covering that
because they look a little different
when you're playing with them welcome
to simply learn there we go so this is
our string and then of course I can come
down here and print s when we run this
you'll see that I have welcome to simply
learn so these are basic three different
objects we are working with when we
split it now we're going to show you the
list first and we can go ahead and print
we'll take our list and we're going to
do our first slice and this lights we're
going to look at a single individual
object on here it's important to
remember that whatever you're looking at
it always begins with zero so if I
wanted to print the first character this
is this one right here where we have the
square brackets because that's our list
and I want to print just the very first
character it always starts with spot
zero so we're going to start with zero
and I'm gonna run this and of course I
get one because that's in the spot zero
and we can also do let's keep it here
and add it in here print list and if we
count it we can go zero one two three
four five six seven eight nine and so we
know that spot nine is at the end of the
list and what's just to zero the list
that we can remember it and this is nine
of the list so we're gonna print what
we're actually looking at here let's go
run and of course four zero and we'll
make it even a little fancier so it says
equal there we go so spot 0 we get 1
spot 9 we get 10 we can of course change
this and we can do right in the middle
there we can do spot 5 and you can see
how you can start to reference any one
of these and so five spot 5 is actually
equal to 6 because 0 1 2 3 4 5 now one
of the problems with this is then if I
wanted to do the last one in the row I
could create this really lengthy code of
lists the one last thing you have to do
let's go ahead and run this this is
interesting it gives me an error why
does it give me an error because out of
range well the length of the list is 10
but the last place is mine so I wouldn't
do this in regular coding and I'm going
to show you how to do it properly here
in just a second but this is pulling the
last element off the list and then you
had minus 1 because it's some like I
said is increments at 0 so 0 to 9 even
though there's 10 elements and we run it
and there's our 10 we can do this very
simply by counting backward and we just
count backwards by minus 1 and we
if we run this I still get the same
answer ten and by the way if you just
list a little variable in the Jupiter
notebook
list the last one you show on the line
will print so this is the same also
putting a print statement in front of it
there we go we'll just do that so this
is another way to do the last one
instead of having to look up and figure
out what the last element is you can do
minus one
you can also do minus 2 and so on so you
can go backwards on each of the element
and so you can see how that negative
value let's just put it back up here so
that we have it with all the other ones
let's do minus 3 there we go so let's
cut this one out from the bottom and run
it and then you getting C minus 3 equals
8 coming in from the other side so if
this is our basic slice with a single
number in here whether it's positive or
negative integer what happens we want to
do two of these and so let's go ahead
and do something similar and still this
print statement up here and instead of
zero
we're gonna go zero to three I'm going
to put two values in here so here's our
two values and I'm just gonna copy and
paste this over here so we can see what
that looks like and we'll run this and
so when we do : in the middle we do just
the first two values this is going to go
ahead and create a slice of this list
and it's going to be one two three so we
start at position zero remember position
zero equals one here and then position
one equals two and so on to position two
and notice that it doesn't print
position three so it does up to this one
so if we have zero of three it is zero
one two that's the actual positions it
pulls and the values for those are 1 2 3
and this allows us also to take a look
it also just as easily do instead of 3
you can put position full let's do 3 to
9 there we go
and I'll copy this over so it matches
our print statement now let's run that
and you can see right here when I do 3
to 9 I get 4 5 6 7 8 9 and let's go
ahead and take this all the way to 10
now remember it doesn't include the last
one so we won't get an error I can run
this and then I get 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 and
what happens when I do 11 hopefully
you've already guessed it it's gonna
give me an error it didn't well why
didn't it well it says if this is bigger
than the end we're not going to throw
we're just gonna go to the end we'll go
back one let's say let's go and keep
this as ten just because I wanted to go
to the end we can also do both the
beginning and the end remember the
beginning zero I could just as easily do
this as minus one which is also the
endpoint so there's our negative we'll
go ahead and run that oops I forgot they
also switch it on the print statement
keep it nice and uniform there we go so
we'll go ahead and run that and you can
see that from the minus one is coming in
minus one here so we do need to change
this and it gives me an empty set well
that didn't work
so how do you know if you're going to
the end well let's take a look at this
let's go back up here where I have a
single digit and we do minus one into
this place and I run this and this of
course if you do minus one fix my print
you can see minus one equals ten if it's
in the first spot now remember it
doesn't include whatever digit this is
so what I do this is minus one how do I
find the very last digit of this this is
simply done by leaving this blank so
when I leave this blank it goes all the
way to the end this is the same I could
easily just as easily do I eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen we'll also go to the
end whatever is over the top or I can
just leave a blank and I will get the
full array here all the way up to ten on
the right hand side we fix our print
statement so it all matches here there
we go and finally we can also let me
just grab just a matter which one I grab
up here what happens when I do minus
three minus one so we're counting from
the right going left and we do minus
three minus one we run that we can see
down here 8 is minus three 9 is minus
one and then the last thing you want to
do with just two digits involved the
first two values of slicing is we can do
an open set from the beginning which
means starting at zero it's the same as
putting a 0 in there to the end so when
we do that from open set from zero to
the end we run that and we'll see here
in the last one it prints all of them so
here's our full array again it just
returns a full array by putting two
blanks in there so just a quick rehash
before we get into doing steps we looked
at looking up a single value we can put
in just that value remember
starts at zero and it's the length of
the list minus one you can just do that
as a minus 1 here or you could put in
length of list minus 1 which is a very
lengthy way of computing it so it's 0 to
9 if you have 10 spaces that's how you
put the pointers to those and then we
looked at slicing out between 0 & 3 3 to
11 again minus 1 points to the 9 it
doesn't point to the end if you want to
get to the end either have to put a
larger value in or just leave it blank
which is what you should do instead just
lets it know it's going to be open-ended
there's reasons to actually use the
larger values if you don't want it to
any be any more than 11 so there's
reasons not to do that I remember this
spot 11 is actually since it starts at 0
is not included place 11 or in the case
of this place 3 is not included in the
count this is 0 1 2 then 3 pointer we're
three points at is not included and then
you can use negatives to denote counting
from the right-hand side going left as
opposed from left to right so this is
our first two positions on the slicing
x' and now we want to get into a step so
let's take a look and see what step
looks like and let's go ahead and print
we'll go ahead and distill one of these
it's still the last one since it has a
lot of stuff in it that's the same you
guys got to be careful when you copy
things down because you might copy
something you don't want let's do a step
two so it's gonna look just like that
so we have all of this so the first two
spaces denote that we're starting from
the very beginning going to the end but
we're going to do a step of two let's
see what that looks like so when I print
that out we get 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 we get 1 3
5 7 & 9 so it skips every other one when
we do step two and then we can do the
same thing but instead of two remember I
said these can all be positive or
negative if we do - - it goes in Reverse
so now we're going from right to left
and we get to 8 6 4 2 and notice the
change up here we have 10 instead of 9
so this started at 1 is skipped and the
starts at the last position going
backwards and it might be that you
needed to start with you want the same
exact numbers you'd have to then add a
minus 1 here to get and
this is kind of an interesting because
you notice here it starts at tense is
counting from the right to the left what
if you wanted the same series we had up
here you'd have to actually come in here
and change the value to minus 2 and this
is interesting
intuitively I look at this and I think
minus 1 but you got to remember reading
from the right to the left and so if you
wanted to take the slice and recreate
this in 9 7 5 3 1 coming from the right
to the left it's going to be reading
this value here so I could change this
just as easily to 8 to get the same
thing let me see if that works there we
go also as a minus 2 it's a little less
intuitive because this starts at 0 and
so it's a minus 2 to actually go back to
the 9 position or the Tempah's ition
again you can also just put in the
number on there and you can see with the
steps we can reverse it this is probably
the most common use for steps as we can
just reverse the whole thing and we do
that simply by setting this to minus 1
over here print statement so it matches
and if I run this there we go I get 10 9
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 so it just reverses our
list we have and it's important to
remember that all of these all work with
our tuple and if you remember correctly
I called it TP l I can use any of these
commands on there and so if I wanted to
take our tuple and I wanted to reverse
it so let me just grab this up here
there we go we can run this and you'll
see that if I do the tuple does the
exact same thing as it did to the list
so the tuple in the list are identical
we do slices easy to remember tuple and
lists what looks a little different
though is when we jump in and do strings
now they're not really different they
just look different because we're
missing out with them we're dealing with
words instead of just a list of objects
but it is just a list of characters so
let's create a variable called welcome
or we're gonna set this equal to welcome
to simply learn how we started off our
setup on here and if we look at welcome
to simply learn these each of these
characters is a space so obstinate me to
switch those the capital W is at 0 the E
and so if I do print do welcome let's
just do 0 it prints out W why because
that's the first letter in here as at
points
we can also do print welcome just like
we did above I can do 11 I think I
counted that right let's find out if I
did good and actually didn't count that
they did in the back so here we have
position 11 on so we go 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 begins with the s and we go
all the way to the end so we have print
welcome you living on was gonna print
simply learn and of course if you're in
a very strange mood we could do welcome
and if you remember from above we're
gonna leave the first two empty minus
one so we're gonna do a step minus one
and if you guessed it we're gonna print
it in reversed order
no really amidst ought ml quo okay
welcome to simply learn and reverse now
before we continue on with strings we
want to take one small detour here and
look at the slice object and I'll call
it my slice equals slice that's the
actual terminology let's see what this
does this is actually a really cool
feature and I'm gonna put the values in
a 1 5 2 and just so we can remember
let's reprint our list we had from above
there shouldn't be that hard to forget
and then I want to print our list here's
our square brackets but instead of
putting the values in there I'm gonna
put my slice in there and let's go ahead
and run that and you should see here's
our full list and then our slice said 1
5 & 2 so it's gonna go from 1 to 5 or in
this case that means 1 2 3 4 and we're
gonna skip 2 so let's see so if we start
at 1 2 3 4 and we're counting by twos we
end up with 2 and 4 and there we have
our slice right there we can do that
with the list and then of course we can
also do that with our text we have going
our welcome to simply learn and we'll do
my slice equals here's our slice and
let's grab the values
let's do minus 1 minus 12 minus 1 and
then if we print and since I've been
Jupiter notebook this is like one of the
cool things I love about Jupiter
notebook is that if I type it out and
just do welcome it will know to print
this now if you're in a different editor
the standard is of course to add print
on there which is real simple
do we can print this out and we end up
with a slice we're going stepping
negative one we're gonna go back minus
one which is the end and we could have
just left this blank by the way well let
me see simply learn yeah welcome to
simply learn we could just left that
blank cuz that would have gone started
from well minus one starts us from the
end we go back minus 12 so there we are
with our simply learned and then of
course it's in Reverse going from right
to left so we've reversed it so a quick
rehash before we look at using a slice
in searching for substrings there's
gonna be the last section on our slicing
we looked at how it works with the
string up here welcome equals welcome to
simply learn how we just slice it apart
and just like we did with our list and
our tuple
we can use the three different values of
plus or minus integers to sort it out in
this case we did it to print simply
learn at the end and then also to put it
all back word and then we looked at
using my slice to create a slice so
here's the variable I assigned when it's
an actual slice and then we just insert
it in there instead of the actual values
this way if you're doing certain things
you don't have to always retype that you
can actually have one variable and then
change it in that variable in that slice
variable and then of course we went
ahead and just showed you how to use my
slice with a string it works the same as
it does with a regular list so what
we're gonna do is we're now gonna write
a program to search for a substring
within a string using slice function and
let's see what that looks like well go
and start with creating a couple inputs
I'll have s for string which input enter
a string and a little space there so it
looks nice and if we run and then sub
equals input enter a substring we'll
just run that show you what that looks
like welcome to simply learn hit enter
and welcome so I've now assigned s and a
substring sub now if this was all I was
doing I would just do s dot find sub and
we want to go and just print this print
s dot find forgot my brackets are on
there there we go and this would
actually work and you will see that it
comes up up here we go I forgot two
types of welcome simply learn and we all
find just simply learn enter and I get
11 so this is what we're gonna do with
this using my slice
this is kind of fun because we're
writing a little bit of code here to see
just to kind of see the back end and how
the stuff fits together and some of the
things you gotta look for when you're
writing script the first one is we can
go ahead and create a couple variables
and we'll call this l string L STR of
length s so the length of the string and
then we'll call an L sub equals the
length of the sub and this does nothing
but give us a total length of what we're
looking at let's just go and print that
it's just you can see we're looking at L
string else up and let me go ahead and
run this and we'll just keep it simple
this time I'm just gonna do simply learn
and just s so we have a length of 11
that's how long the words simply learn
is and of course s is only a length of
one and so the first thing you'd want to
note is that if L sub the length of the
sub is greater than the string then
we'll do something like print error
'invalid substring exit so we know that
this is invalid so you're looking for
exceptions or bass rules is always
important in any of our script now again
for this particular example I would just
do a stop find the sub and just find our
sub in there so we can test this out and
if we do let's just do simply learn
enter and let's go welcome through i'm
just type tip that's okay simply learn
it's gonna say invalid substring why
because it's too long
oops it might exited the kernel not a
problem on there that's because we're in
Jupiter notebook and the exit exits the
code and then it restarts the kernel if
you're not familiar with kernels the
kernel is what we're running and that is
the actual script runs in this kernel
that's the code executing so we can
restart and clear output restart and
Reynolds there's a kernel read runs all
your code that's part of Jupiter
notebook the fact that we're in a
separate environment this isn't the
actual computer running it but the but a
kernel that's running it with the called
kernel and then we want to go ahead and
listed a flag flag equals let's make it
true this is right now if everything
goes right we'll turn the flag to false
if everything looks good
then we know we got the right answer so
we'll do flag equals true on here and
then we want to iterate through
different values in our string we'll use
is a pointer so this is pointing to
different parts of string now we're
going to do it in a range we're gonna
start with zero so the first position
and we're gonna go this is gets a little
loops and fix that a little bit mixed
your common there there we go we're
gonna do links of string
- lengths of the sub plus one so what
this means is we're gonna look at chunk
all the way up to the - the length of
the sub of text we don't need to do the
end of it because then we're just going
over the end of our string so it doesn't
make sense to test for last five plus
four more that's what this is a soror
link the string - leave the sub plus one
and I'm important there because remember
how our range goes it starts at zero
going over let's create my slice will
create a slice object and this is going
to be extracting every sub strength of
link sub from the string so we want to
create a slice and this life is just
simply I for rate for I and range 0
store starts at 0 1 2 3 4 - I plus L sub
so it's the length of our sub string we
just did that's where that's all coming
from it will create a temp string okay
this equal to our string and we're gonna
break this up by my slice by our object
now certainly you could do this by just
putting these values in here and you
could make this compress this down
Python you'd want to do that to make it
more readable and less lines of code the
reason to expand it is sometimes you
want to do a lot more than just know
where the point is where it starts or
located you might be looking for other
things on here and so by breaking it up
maybe nothing comes to mind immediately
on the tempest but it might be that
we're gonna be swapping things in and
out so knowing the slice size and the
dimensions of the slice may be really
important if I want to keep the document
the same length so maybe I'm gonna be
adding spaces and or something to
reformat it so there's all kinds of
reasons to break it down into this again
if you were just gonna find the the sub
value in there we already did that print
s not fine sup but you might be
manipulating it and doing a lot more
with it than just finding it so it's
kind of fun to walk through the code and
so we'll do a simple thing if tip s
equals the sub
so if our temp slice equals the sub then
yay we have it so we
reset our flag as equal to false so our
flag is true if we have a problem no
flag it's all good and then we want to
go ahead and print and let's do print
substring found at position and wear
position I this is kind of nice because
you could actually have multiple
instances and it's gonna print out each
instance so you could address each one
differently depending on what you're
working on as we set our flag to false
we print our string I will do a simple
break the break just interrupts our 4i
statement on here so if we didn't want
to print all the different locations it
would just print the first one that's
what this break does here and then if
you remember correctly we raised a flag
and from the beginning I say the flag is
true so if flag print and we'll say some
string not found and let's go ahead and
run this and see what happens this is
kind of well let me write at first this
is runner runs through and here's our
string welcome true well we'll just do
two substring found position eight and
you can see here it matches the print
substring and it matches it down here so
let's just take a quick look breakdown
of this before we wrap it up we showed
you how to do a quick find for a string
it's a string function but then we
wanted to do it in slice and in slice we
have our first setup that says hey are
there any base values that just aren't
going to work it's an invalid string
print the invalid string if our length
of our sub is greater than the length of
the string so you look for logic in
there that's gonna say hey this is a
problem and then we went ahead and set a
flag equals to true so it says hey I'm
raising a flag here but we're going to
test it out and change it to false and
you could use 0 & 1 there's all kinds of
things you can use on there and then we
did for I and range 0 to the length of
string minus the link sub plus 1 so
we're gonna iterate through each of the
different positions on there we create
our slice we test our slice we say hey
the slice is true in doing so we change
the flag to false so when it gets to the
flag is as up we're all good don't worry
no flag here no problem keep going your
Star Wars fans you might be these are
not the droids you're looking for
no that would be if there was a flag and
we're covering it up and be different
please here flag false and then we print
our answer and you can replace this with
some
very complicated code we're swapping in
a new string for the old string they
come up here just return a list of the
positions it could return the word
before that might be something important
so maybe you have to go in there and
look at sub strings and expand it going
before this point there's a lot of
things you can do with this so we look
at this code and you're saying well
that's just why don't we just do s find
you might be doing a lot more stuff in
here than just finding where that
position is so we've covered a lot today
we covered how to slice lists tuples and
strings all three of them with the three
different steps the start-stop step and
so on and so we've learned all three of
those different setups we've seen how to
apply that to string list or tuple that
wraps it up for our slice tutorial again
thank you for joining us here at simply
learned that's wwwo
get certified get ahead if you have any
questions feel free to visit us on our
website where we have a team willing to
help and you can also post your
questions down below in the youtube
video area where has comments and we
will be monitoring that again thank you
for joining us today and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here